plus de 400 personnes se sont
rassemblées ce matin dans les rues de
mâcon pour rendre hommage à rachid 32
ans tué d'un coup de couteau la semaine
dernière une marche silencieuse de
recueillement et de dignité en tant
citer les organisateurs dans le cortège
des membres de sa famille et des amis
qui ont souhaité lui rendre hommage
mais ils avaient tous un général ont
joué ensemble quand on était petit signe
c'est vraiment triste que justice soit
faite
oui ça me met vraiment c'est une
personne très très très très agréable au
quotidien on a fait du sport ensemble
c'est une personne agréable à vivre
souriant très honnête
jamais jamais un mot plus haut que
l'autre
très souriant et aimable le cortège
s'est dirigé vers le square de la paix
en passant par le palais de justice les
membres de la famille et les amis qui
demande une avancée de l'anc est dans le
même temps la police a lancé un appel à
témoins pour en connaître plus sur les
circonstances du drame